[Music]
[Applause]
Mike Florio his book Father of Mine
about the mob in 1973 available online
wherever books are sold he of course is
uh the popular co-host of pro football
talk live that precedes this program on
peacock and he contributes to NBC's
football night America Mike good to have
you back
um what stands out what was the one
thing that stood out from the schedule
release
well we all wanted to see when where how
often we would witness the Jets with
Aaron Rodgers in Standalone games six in
all four more that start at 4 25 PM
Eastern which are big audience games
those generate huge ratings on CBS or
Fox and
when you look at their schedule and Dan
this is something to keep in mind
because everybody's going to expect the
Jets to make it to the playoffs there's
a quirk in the schedule where you have a
rotation every year
every team from a given division plays
all of the teams from one of the other
divisions in the conference and all of
the teams from one of the divisions in
the other conference and it just both
rotate every year and it and it fits
together and this year it has landed
like The Wheel of Fortune on AFC West
and NFC East that's half your schedule
against two of the better divisions in
the NFL yeah so
when you start talking about wild card
births
and and also you're cannibalizing six
games
of your own schedule against your
division rivals
I'm not so sure more than one team is
getting out of the AFC East this year
with a playoff spot whoa I don't know
that one of those other teams is getting
a wild card berth and you look at the
Jets they got the Chiefs the Eagles and
the Cowboys in the first five weeks they
got some tough games and they may not
make it to the playoffs but then you're
saying the Dolphins may not make it to
the playoffs and the Patriots not making
the plans
it may be one team in one team only
that's why week one for the Jets is so
critical Dan because if they lose to the
bills at home and then they have to go
play at Buffalo later you get swept by
the bills good luck beating out the
bills for the division title if the
bills have swept you beaten you twice
and hold the head-to-head tiebreaker so
that week one game is critical those
early season games are huge for the Jets
do you think the Jets roster is ready
for this we know Rogers can be but the
Jets roster their coach the coverage now
it's you're not a oh you're the Jets now
you're you're the oh you're the Jets
expectation level is through the roof
and part of it is you embrace it because
along the way you make a lot of money
you get a lot of attention you get to
bask in the spotlight even if at the end
of the day you're on the sideline
watching the other teams play in the
postseason so there's different ways to
define success from a business
standpoint only one team wins the Super
Bowl but all the other teams have to
make money and the Jets have been
Irrelevant for so long this is their
moment however it plays out and I
interviewed Joe Douglas the GM of the
Jets yesterday and I tried to figure out
what's that line of demarcation between
success and failure what does it take
for you to say we did the right thing
here and it's going to be fascinating
you see kids are never going to admit to
us they're never going to say I mean we
really screwed that up we never should
have traded for Aaron Rodgers but
they're going to be relevant they're
going to be present they're going to
make money but how good are they going
to be and you raise a great point you
got they got a lot of young players who
are gonna have to grow up quickly if
they want to compete especially if they
start off two and four through their
first six games which isn't impossible I
brought this up I don't know if you had
any further information on it but when's
the last time a team that didn't make
the playoffs from the preceding year
opened up in the first game of the
season against the defending champs so
that's a great question it's a great
question and
I I didn't consider the Lions as a
candidate
for that opening game in part because I
wasn't sure the NFL would fully lean
into this Buzz that the Lions have
developed but when I saw that that's the
first game I thought this is great this
is great you know the Lions have not
been relevant forever not since Barry
Sanders I think you could argue maybe
2012 but that year they were terrible
Calvin Johnson set the all-time single
season receiving yardage record and they
had Matthew Staffing that and Dominican
Sue but they weren't great
it's been a very long time 31 years
since they've won a playoff game for
crying out loud but I I think it's
fascinating but you're right the Lions
haven't proven anything they've got a
high bar but they're not much CTV Mike I
think they're a good team
when I say the lines you think of their
head coach that's what I found
interesting uh you know the Vikings
aren't interesting they might be a good
coach or a good team but
this is the opening night I just found
that interesting that if you were going
to have a game do you need to have a
game where we're tuning in for both of
these teams as
as the employee allow me to to make a
case for watching the first game of the
season and you know Dan look at the
captive audience games this year
I think the NFL decided not to drop
great games into the spots where they
know that we're going to watch anywhere
we're going to watch on Thanksgiving why
are we going to burn Jets at Cowboys on
Thanksgiving I thought there was a
chance that would be the Thanksgiving
game why do it why bother okay we're
still going to tune in and watch
commanders Cowboys what else are we
going to do Christmas games Raiders
Chiefs okay fine we're going to watch
anyway it's not a not one of the great
games on the schedule but drop it there
and I think that same mindset may have
applied here people are still going to
tune in to watch Patrick Holmes he has
transcended football he is now a star
met gal at Kentucky Derby everywhere you
look there's Patrick Mahomes and the
Lions do have that up and coming Vibe
they've got an enigmatic and and
Charming head coach who everybody wants
to hear from so they could have done a
lot worse than the Lions and I think
it'll do a huge number and they kept in
the bag one of the great games Eagles
Chiefs for example you know one of the
games we looked at and said well that's
likely to be the week one opener they
hold it for later in the year
why are the Dolphins and Chiefs playing
in in Germany
Dan we got a lot of people that watch
our show on Sky Sports Action that's
what they call it in the off season at
Sky Sports NFL in the regular season
there are a ton of passionate
UK NFL fans I don't think there are
enough I don't think it gets enough play
in London I think this game in Germany
Dolphins Chiefs is an acknowledgment
that the ceiling may be higher in
Germany yeah I agree than it is in
England yeah and about if I'm in British
fan of the NFL and we've been kissing
frogs for 16 years with these crap games
you've been sending over they get Tom
Brady their first year they get Patrick
Mahomes versus Tyree kill the second
year what are we well I the fervor the
excitement Peter King says it was like
attending a conference Championship game
going to that game in Germany and I
think the NFL is understanding that and
embracing it more worthy of Prime Time
games in your opinion if I said the
Chargers are Cincinnati Chargers have
six Bengals have four
well you know what I'd say the Bengals
are more worthy of that platform and
that presence because Joe burrow is just
fun to watch the team is great at this
point
but with the charges you can always
count on them doing something to make a
game interesting you and and you know
the very dated reference that I make
about the Chargers they they're my
Roseanne Rosanna Danna team it's always
something with the Chargers so they're
going to give you something they're
they're gonna they're gonna turn a bad
game into a good game they're gonna turn
a good game into a bad game they're
going to blow a 27 point lead they keep
it entertaining so I kind of like having
the chance to study the Chargers
carefully the most interesting bad team
is
probably the Rams
because they are a bad team now they
can't call themselves a good team
anymore they are going to compete with
the Cardinals for the basement of the
NFC West and they have a tough schedule
right out of the gates and I think it's
going to be fascinating to see how this
goes with Matthew Stafford who's an old
35 Aaron Donald doing what he can to
load it up for one more year with the
Rams and I think he'll be done with the
Rams after this year Sean McVeigh
teetered enough about whether he was
going to come back to make that an issue
this year even though he's trying not to
make it one and if the Chargers continue
to get better it makes it even more
glaring if the Rams struggle Mike Florio
pro football talk live co-host and his
new book father of mine it's about the
mob in the early 70s available online
wherever books are sold Tom Brady
uh I guess the report out of ESPN is he
is going to be buying it as a partner of
the Raiders
it's funny how ESPN reports this very
sensitive and developing information
about Brady possibly buying part of the
Raiders when they knew damn well he was
possibly buying part of the Dolphins
last year and they never said a word
about it
I I just
how they pick and choose which sensitive
topics they're going to go wait what why
wouldn't they report on the Dolphins I
don't know I don't know but plenty of
people knew about the Dolphins last year
and they kept their mouths shut and I'd
love to know why people kept their
mouths shut up why do you think I I
because Tom Brady wasn't okay with it
getting out and he's okay with this
getting out and he wasn't okay with it
getting out a year ago that's my only
explanation so that's why I thought it
was just funny to see it couched as
sensitive and developing if it was
sensitive it was truly sensitive they
wouldn't be reporting on it because Tom
Brady would have told Don Yi to tell
Chef D to not report on it it would have
been that simple I don't want to go that
far behind the curtain I don't want to
go too far inside baseball but that was
just as somebody who covers this every
day and is always plugged into the
Matrix I thought it was funny that this
gets reported when they knew damn well
last year he was going to be part owner
of the Dolphins and then play for the
Dolphins and it was
nobody said anything
except us
help me understand the Jaguars situation
with their Stadium
are they they they have to renovate and
then they have to move someplace for
their home games and are they going to
go to Orlando
where do the Jags go what is it a
two-year period we're talking about
coming up this first popped up on
Wednesday the outgoing mayor of
Jacksonville said if they're going to
renovate this Stadium the way they want
to it's going to be best case scenario
day in two years where the Jaguars can't
play in that Stadium I
where you find another NFL ready stadium
in town you're gonna have to go
somewhere and their lease runs through
2029 so
you're displaced for two years and if
you're going to do this renovation I'm
assuming you're going to extend the
lease and you're going to be tied to
Jacksonville indefinitely I just feel
like this is the point where it's going
to go one way or the other there's
either going to be a renewal of the vows
with Jacksonville which still will
result in two years of playing somewhere
else maybe London or
the clock ticks toward 2029 and out go
the Jaguars to London and I know folks
in Jacksonville don't want to hear it
but I remember vividly folks in St Louis
didn't want to hear it when the
handwriting was on the wall that the
Rams were going to La and everybody knew
it except the folks in St Louis because
the NFL was lying to them and the Rams
were lying to them about their
intentions
in this case you know the commissioner
talking about a 14 division eventually
in Europe well unless it's going to be
four expansion teams
a number one choice is the Jaguars so I
just feel like this whole process is so
weird that the end result is either
going to be Jaguars forever in
Jacksonville or Jaguars on a steam ship
to London Are we more likely to have a
Super Bowl what happens first Super Bowl
outside the United States or a team
outside the United States team team I I
think Super Bowl is something that gets
kind of thrown around just
for craps and Giggles but it's never
going to happen they're going to start a
Super Bowl at 1am
British time to suit our TV pattern so I
I think it's going to be a team once the
commissioner talked about four teams
that tells me that this talk of one team
that's been around for over a decade
isn't just dangling a carrot to get
people in Europe interested at some
point they're going to have to put teams
there starting with two in London and
then maybe two in Germany
well is there an expansion city in the
United States
I think there would be potential
expansion cities St Louis would be
perfect if the NFL could ever get over
the fact that they had to pay St Louis
nearly 800 million dollars for lying
their asses off to the people in St
Louis about not moving the Rams to LA
and they did they lied and lied and
that's why they paid nearly 800 million
dollars to St Louis when it was all said
and done St Louis would be perfect and
one I talked to somebody about this
within the past year or two
you could justify smaller markets just
build a smaller Stadium because
it's now all about
TV Revenue
for that upper deck on a stadium you
know I've talked to owners about this
the money that they make and the cost
that they incur to fill out an upper
deck of an NFL stadium it's really not
worth it and I think there are some
groups now that would say if we were
doing it all over again we just would
get rid of the upper deck that it's not
entailing the profit margin that it
justifies so you know you put in
Oklahoma City you put in Columbus Ohio
you put you know there's there's
different cities that aren't major
massive 80 000 seatings you know are
going to be filled up every week you
could put a 40 000 seat Stadium there
fill it every week and as long as those
games are on TV it's a win for the NFL
have a great weekend Mike good luck with
the book thanks for joining us thanks
Dan good talking to you that's Mike
Florio pro football talk live co-host
we'll take a break